There are other avengers. It'll
get you back on the lunch box.
No pressure then
Welcome back everyone
this is going to be my moon knight video
for doctor strange if khonshu and
ammit and the rest of the ennead,
the pantheon that they come from the egyptian
gods are such a threat to the main mcu dimension
why doesn't doctor strange try to stop them
because that is his main job protecting
our reality a lot of that is related to what's
happening during the events of the doctor strange
2 trailer spider-man no way home and thor love and
thunder with all the other lesser gods of the mcu
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i'm doing videos
for all the moon knight episodes and we're
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post all your theories in the comments below
during the previous marvel movies we've seen
so far we've learned a little bit about the
higher order of cosmic beings and lesser gods
in the mcu technically a difference like higher
order cosmic beings can become lesser gods but
typically cosmic beings like the celestials are
completely different from the lesser gods their
powers all come from different places they're all
big threats though now we're seeing more of the
multiverse during marvel phase four i know there's
lots of questions about what the difference
between dimensions and different universes are
i'll explain that during the video too because
there is an important distinction a lot of the
marvel phase 4 movies use the term interchangeably
especially during that first doctor strange movie
when technically he's moving across different
dimensions not across different universes
the newest threat to the entire mcu that they
just explained during moon knight episode 1 is
that the egyptian pantheon the khonshu and ammit
come from just the egyptian gods not all the gods
are threatening to physically enter the main mcu
dimension again once upon a time they did exist
inside the main mcu dimension but then they chose
to leave humanity traveling to another dimension
another plane of existence and they exist there
currently and that's where kancho is speaking to
moon knight from because he's only inside his head
he's not physically inside the main mcu dimension
there are a lot of lesser gods that did exist
inside the main mcu dimension like you have thor
he is a lesser god he's inside the mcu you had
people like odin and hella they existed inside
the main mcu briefly when these super powerful
cosmic beings and other lesser gods are outside
of the main mcu dimension they're still super
powerful but their powers to mess with what's
going on inside the mcu are greatly weakened so if
ethan hawke's arthur harrow villain character is
successful in bringing amit the devourer of souls
into the main mcu dimension she'll get this huge
power boost if she were to physically enter
the mcu main dimension she wouldn't have that
limitation she could use her power to go full
minority report on everybody at the same time
instantly so during avengers infinity war doctor
strange literally told iron man in that great
scene of them having their big bro off moment that
his main job is protecting their reality the main
mcu dimension from threats inside and outside
their dimension that's actually the main purpose
of all the special enchantments around the earth
formed by the different sanctums all over the
world when you see the symbols of the vashanti
cover the earth in this scene here they're the
same symbols that you see in the windows of all
the different sanctums together they all form
a protective magical barrier that prevents super
powerful beings like dormammu other cosmic beings
lesser gods from entering the mcu dimension and
attacking earth any time they feel like it doctor
strange also said that he keeps a watch list of
all the big threats to earth that are currently
inside the mcu so one of the main reasons why
doctor strange has allowed arthur harrow and
ahmed to gain this many followers for so long a
time all the other sorts of supremes have done
the same thing too because arguably this has been
going on for a long time potentially threatening
the mcu in such a huge way is mostly because for
instance in present day doctor strange understands
the idiot he understands the relationship between
khonshu amid the other gods that are part of their
family part of his training involves reading a lot
of books and learning about how all the different
lesser gods of the mcu exist so he knows a little
bit about some of these other gods he doesn't know
everything but he knows about the existence of
a lot of these higher order beings and he's read
about how konchu has made it his mission along
all these years with the support of the other gods
to keep amit from being able to enter the mcu
physically khonshu could also try to physically
enter the mcu if he wanted to and become way more
powerful he is a dirtbag to be true but he's not
that crazy at least not yet he's very capricious
he does not care about humanity or other people
just in general but he also doesn't want to
see the utter destruction of the entire third
dimension given enough time eventually everybody
would think about doing something evil and they'd
be judged and killed off so they'd eventually lose
every single follower they have and as a result no
one would believe in them and they'd eventually
fade into nothingness a lot of the lesser god's
power levels come from their access to the faith
of their followers so they still have a lot of
power when they're outside the main mcu dimension
but if they physically entered the mcu in regular
people saw them and started believing in them
again they quickly get way way more powerful
with all the power of that faith and be able to
eventually change the mcu however they wanted
kind of like the infinity stones for those of you
asking no they're not as powerful as the infinity
stones especially when they're trapped outside
the main mcu dimension they'd have to get every
single person inside the mcu to believe in them
as gods and even the other universes of the third
dimension theoretically and then they would get
powerful enough to be as powerful as the infinity
stones but it would just take so long for that to
happen and so many things would have to go right
that is very unlikely that that would ever happen
one of the clues as to why this enid this group of
gods that khonshu belongs to initially left many
thousands of years ago is in the beginning of moon
knight episode one remember when stephen grant is
trying to stay away early in the episode reading
all this egyptian history on the eniot itself
the books talk about the egyptian gods turning
away from humans not caring about them as much
because of the rise of technology humans started
believing in technology more than the actual
gods believing in them less making them weaker
so initially a lot of the gods left the main mcu
dimension because people just stopped caring about
them the other reason why this particular group
of gods stays inside that other dimension away
from the mcu is because arthur harrow said the
other gods is part of that and he had learned what
ammit was trying to do entered the mcu and judge
everybody at the same time so they wanted to stop
her so they're kind of keeping themselves in this
alternate reality to prevent her from entering the
main mcu so one of the main reasons why doctor
strange and all the previous sorcerer supremes
like agamotto himself i guess you could call wang
one of the sorcerer supremes because technically
he is currently the sorcerer's supreme if you
think about the eternals movie merlin was also
probably the source of supreme during his era
on earth they all probably relied on those gods
policing themselves inside this alternate
dimension we've all watched the doctor strange
2 trailer a billion times currently doctor strange
is preoccupied with scarlet witch trying to enact
her plan to use the dark hold in america chavez
to travel the third dimension multiverse until she
can find a version of billy and tommy and in the
process cause a whole bunch of chaos potentially
breaking a lot of the protective enchantments and
restrictions that prevent super powerful cosmic
beings and lesser gods from entering the main
mcu and wreaking all kinds of havoc so it's like
a here we go again kind of situation like we go
from avengers end game with the infinity gauntlet
threatening the entire mcu to a bunch of gods in
scarlet witch threatening the entire mcu same old
problems just a different day just to explain
the difference between dimensions and universes
like we talk about the multiverse and doctor
strange 2 all these different x-men multiverse
characters showing up the main difference is
that the main mcu for instance is now technically
called the marvel cinematic multiverse it contains
infinite worlds inside the third dimension with
other variants of characters like spider man no
way home with all the different tobey maguire
andrew garfield versions of peter parker all these
different people of the third dimension exist in a
similar reality with minor differences when you
start talking about traveling between different
dimensions though typically you're talking
about traveling between different orders of
existence there's a lot of time travel in the mcu
so time is a good example that so in the third
dimension you witness time as you move forward or
backwards through it but if somehow you were able
to physically enter the fourth dimension like a
higher order dimension you would witness all the
timeline everything that has happened everything
is happening or everything that will happen in
the future all instantaneously at the same time
in the same moment that's actually how ammit
exists inside the moon knight series the reason
why she can detect everything evil that anyone
has ever done is doing or will do is because she
can see the entire timeline simultaneously all in
the same instant so inside the marvel movies the
marvel tv series when they talk about traveling
between different dimensions they also use the
term interchangeably they call it the multiverse
you could call different dimensions part of the
multiverse but really each different dimension
has its own specific multiverse that exists inside
a similar reality most of what we're seeing in the
doctor strange two trailer at least so far is
different universes coming together from just
the third dimension what we saw in the first
doctor strange movie is a better example of
different dimensions so like dormammu for instance
becomes a higher order cosmic being that exists
on a different level from other normal people
and he exists in a different dimension that's
trying to absorb the main mcu dimension they
changed a little bit about the thor characters
too in the comics technically they exist as
higher order beings from another dimension
but inside the mcu movies they try to give a more
scientific explanation so the character's origin
story is a little bit different and they're just
normal cosmic beings from a different place that
you could fly to inside the third dimension who
eventually are able to gain enough power to become
lesser gods the rest of the moon-eyed episodes
will help answer a lot of these questions too
like what is the difference between a cosmic
being and a lesser god like a legit god
in the mcu remember a lot of it has to
do with where people's powers come from
and how they exist inside different dimensions but
my full moon knight episode 2 video will post next
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss that everyone click here for
all my moon knight episode videos and click here
for my doctor strange 2 trailer video and easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!